people on the internet have offered me
thousands of dollars for pictures of my
feet and this is that story so I was
acting in a video for the key of awesome
where there was a guy parody pitbull and
I was playing a winter girl and he
tickled the bottom of my feet after the
video they saw there was a spike of
views during that section of the video
and as soon as they uploaded it a bunch
of screenshots appeared of my feet on
wiki feet all sudden people started
reaching out and e-mailing me about my
toes and my soles I never thought much
of my feet after dancing and doing point
my whole life the appearance of my toes
right never anything I would brag about
there are people reaching out to me and
offering me money for my used ballet
slippers and my dirty socks it weirded
me out at first and I tried to get the
pictures taken down but things go on the
internet and they stay there forever so
I ignored it and moved on I started to
notice that any picture where I had
sandals on would go up on the site it
wasn't until I moved to LA and had one
of my first tinder dates with a
Hollywood type who informed me that any
actor worth talking about had a wiki
feat page and the fact that my page was
so popular means I must be doing well
the weirdest was when I did this college
humor video that only showed my feet in
my legs I wasn't credited in the video
but people recognized my feet not sure
how the viewers spotted me from just my
feet but they found me it was kind of
embarrassing at first because the
production found out after numerous
comments about my feet and I had to
explain to them that my feet were famous
I was nervous at casting people would
Google me for acting work and just find
pictures of my feet thinking that I was
some kind of like fetish person or
something I feel violated when people
post pictures of my feet that I didn't
think would go up on there now I have to
deal with pressure of always making sure
my feet look good like I did my toes
especially for this video because I
figured they may be on camera but I've
decided to just take it as a compliment
okay at least they're not saying
anything bad about your toes sometimes
you do get stalkers people showing up at
your house I've had to move several
times my sister actually unfriended me
on Facebook because she just doesn't
want to be associated she's like scared
um so it's it's weird it's definitely
strange
I've had people find my phone number and
call me and ask me to smash eggshells
with my toes I don't I don't know what
that's about
I got DM from this like foot fetish page
that offered me $1500 to just video my
feet like walking and then he was just
like you know if you could just step on
like you know bananas I didn't respond I
just thought it was really really weird
I have a line so I said no to that just
morally I couldn't I couldn't do it even
though it would it help pay my rent even
though there are crazy people out there
there's still moments in life where I
get to come here and talk about we're
literally making a video about my feet
right now which i think is hysterical
because I don't know just there my feet
okay Peter gross Oh at least I think so
but I mean some people don't so the fact
that there are people out there that
like them I just don't want you to know
that I appreciate you guys